and with the demand for testing so high
right now it's really no surprise that
most sites do have long lines and that
leaves some turning to places like
private labs for quicker results but
that's going to cost you victoria saha
joining us in studio and victoria you
were able to see firsthand just how busy
these labs are right
yeah denise it was pretty surprising
after seeing the huge lines for our
public free testing sites these private
labs are also booked up every single day
but it comes with a hefty price
two hundred and fifty dollars that's how
much a pcr cova test will cost you at e7
health the technology costs us more and
we the staffing for it so it costs more
but for the people who need it and need
it that quickly at least it's available
nick from montreal is someone who tells
us he needs it despite the price i
travel a lot so every time i have to get
tested three times for each trip
so just the prices of the test is
usually more than my plane ticket
convenience really seems to be the top
priority for those patients coming into
private testing labs over here at e7
health you can get tested
and get your results back within an hour
the private testing lab has more than 50
machines that can test for covert 19.
straight into our dock owner dr jonathan
bakhtari says the demand has skyrocketed
since the holidays as the mild omicron
variant spreads rapidly the phones just
will not stop if there's two lines that
would be a positive e-7 has been testing
more than 2 000 people a week with an
average wait time of 20 minutes to get
tested take out a sample one man we
spoke to was waiting all day at the ymca
testing site but was turned away as the
site closed early but he needed to get
tested for work i definitely didn't
expect to pay 250 dollars but it's
something i have to do for the job
opportunity
so we took a poll asking you if you
would pay more than 50 dollars for a
test here are the results more than
eighty percent of you said no and for
those wondering my test results they
were emailed to me and they came back
negative brian back to you glad to hear
that victoria health insurance expert we
spoke with says test on through private
labs can be submitted for reimbursement
but it's usually only approved if that
test is medically necessary however the
biden administration is requiring
insurers to reimburse americans for
at-home tests that change kicks in this
saturday